When we use any manmade tool or device,
we typically look to its form and
design to give us an idea of
what it does and how it works.
A classic example is a kettle.
I can look at this kettle and recognize
that the handle side is the one I'm
meant to grab,
even if I've never seen one before,
because I've seen the same basic shape
on things like coffee mugs, pots,
pitchers, and various other things.
It serves a practical purpose.
It's shaped so I can comfortably get
my hand around it, and it's insulated.
But also, the fact that I've seen many
similar handles before gives me a visual
clue here.
After all, I could probably pick
the kettle up by the spout if I really
wanted, although I'd probably
end up burning myself, and
it'd be pretty tricky to
pour water out of it.
When it comes to graphical
user interfaces,
affordances still represent
the actions we can take.
But now they moment of far is cool
since there's no physical object to
interact with.
Some classic examples of technology
affordances are buttons, you will be
hard pressed to find any software UI
without at least one button on it, and
sliders from scroll bars to
playback controls to price limits.
Something I like to think about is how
real world objects get translated into
purely visual metaphors to
create those affordance cues for
graphical user interfaces.
For example, you can clearly see
a button on a keyboard reflected in
a button element and a checkbox on
a ballot paper in a checkbox element.
While some graphical UI
influences may not be immediately
obvious to new users, for example,
someone new to computers might need to
experiment to learn to use scroll bars.
People generally learn the visual cues
quickly with little or no training.
Well designed affordances enable people
to do something with as little training
as possible.